[Music]
you
hi it's so nice to be here I heard
you're ridiculously happy is this true
like some people came early just to hang
out and many of you are never leaving in
order to just hang out so I'm also I'm
really proud of the school to pull this
together I know that this is one of the
first times you've had this type of
conference so anyway thank you for being
here and it's a pleasure to be here as
well so I'm going to talk a little bit
about power of story but I'm going to
foreshadow a couple of other bodies of
research that we've been doing recently
most because it's really fun for me to
talk about the research so I wanted to
start off with a recent study that I ran
with some co-authors and this was using
a large data set of 12 million data
points it's called the we feel fine data
set and what my co-author said Kivar and
his colleague Jonathan Harris did was
write a computer algorithm that combed
the blogosphere for all mentions of I
feel and I am feeling and so because
blog based data demographic data that
you can scrape they were able to in a
single slide basically document what
people are feeling at wet ages and so
this is a data set that was collected
over three years a cross-cultural data
set 12 million data points in a single
slide and the way to read this
particular slide is we start out simple
so how many of you have sort of 11 to 14
year olds raise your hand okay so when
you ask like how are you feeling they
say fine like what'd you do today
nothing all day I did nothing it's been
you know 12 hours and I did nothing so
there's not this rich emotional lexicon
associated with this team but we soon
fill up with angst at 15 to 18 they
start to feel very anxious when they do
feel happy we show that what they mean
is they feel excited
which is a very angsty form of happiness
and then feelings of confinement around
21 they start to feel not very well
understood or or known until we leave
those feelings behind to go conquer the
world at 21
they start to feel a little bit more
powerful the meaning of happiness
equates more to feeling hopeful
optimistic that you could have money
power status or that you might already
start to have it the meaning of
happiness is much more associated with
sort of satisfaction or pride in what
you're doing
and then we drug I gradually trade those
feelings for around admission for
balance around 30 people start to blog
about losing balance needing more
balance they haven't seen their families
or worked out in a long time then they
develop an appreciation for their
physical bodies start talking about how
they feel sort of fat or unhealthy
because again all of a sudden their
bodies went downhill without them
knowing at age 35 and then we start
blogging about our children we're only
as happy as our least happy child and
evolving sense of connectedness around
44 which we feel happy calm blessed and
grateful and and so the meaning of
happiness migrates from excitement to
feelings of sort of satisfaction and
pride to feeling a balance and then
migrating to feelings of impact and then
connectedness or peacefulness and and
this is important for a few reasons one
is and by the way it's not that people
die when there were 60 it's just that
the blog based data is not as large
there's not a ton of 60 year old
bloggers these these sample sizes are
huge and so this this data sets
interesting for a couple reasons one is
that I always give this data set usually
to my students teaching the power of
story class so that they mine the data
in order to tell the story with these
large data sets so that they debunk the
feeling that story is this abstract
esoteric touchy-feely thing and that
data is this hard objective thing but
when you give people large datasets and
they start to analyze them they
understand that data scientists are
essentially storytellers and so telling
the story in the data becomes really
important and this slide does that but
the second reason I share it is because
it really underscores some of the
fallacies we have in our research aren't
happiness
so some of our research on happiness
which is blossomed in the last three
decades or so shows that we often
implicitly pursue happiness that being
happy is at the core of our
decision-making so we're optimizing for
some utility function that utility
function is usually happiness you know
is this gonna bring me happy yes but
what our research shows is that even
though we might pursue happiness this
work shows that once we achieve a
certain sense of happiness excitement or
or satisfaction or balance or even
impact that the meaning of happiness
migrates in these really systematic ways
every 5 or 10 years and so it questions
this notion of are we making decisions
in the right way
what is well-being more generally and
how might we be making decisions for our
organizations and our clients and our
employees and our family if this sort of
hedonic treadmill doesn't persist or is
not a is not the right model to be
following so our work shows that if you
aim for meaning something that's deeply
meaningful or purposeful people end up
becoming much happier meaning and
purpose is a pretty esoteric word so
what we do is we run studies to be able
to parse what happiness is versus what
meaning is and so in one particular
study my co-authors and I wanted to dive
into what creates a happy life versus a
meaningful life and we asked individuals
a large set of individuals across
studies you know simple questions like
do you believe you have a happy life in
general are you happy one two seven
Likert scale and then we asked them do
you believe that you have a meaningful
life again the same type of scale and so
these two constructs are positively
correlated if you feel like you have a
lot of happiness you you likely have a
lot of meaning about 0.5 variances
commonly explained but if you partial
out the positive covariance and these
two constructs and you just look at
those individuals that say that they
feel happy but not that meaningful
versus meaningful but not that happy you
get these huge differences in these two
types of people the first big difference
is that
individuals who say that they are happy
but don't have a meaningful life they
say that they want to feel good they
like to feel good all the time they like
to feel very good and they don't want to
feel bad the meaningful individuals like
to also feel good and in a report
feeling good a lot of the time but they
also are not as concerned about never
feeling negative effect so they know
that life is much more sort of a
rollercoaster there's ups and downs than
that in fact defines life the second
biggest difference is that happiness is
more about giving on getting and it's
more self oriented so our happiness
individuals say that they think about
themselves a lot they like to receive
gifts from others the meaningfulness
individuals really like to give to
others they're much more focused on
reading the room how are others feeling
they know that sort of how people
remember you and what you did to them
and how you made them feel is more
important than what you get right now
and then the third biggest difference is
that the individuals that rated
themselves as happy they're very focused
on how they feel right now and the
meaningfulness individuals they were
much more focused on what the past met
with the present means and what the
future means that how these things work
together so the reason to share with you
these stories is because I'm trying to
make the case around meaning which is
important both in life but also at work
there's research to show that
individuals that say that they feel
meaning at work or feeling connected to
purpose are not just three times more
likely to stay but one point seven times
higher in terms of ratings on a job
satisfaction and one point four times
more engaged so there's a real
quantitative benefit for individuals
feeling connected to work which usually
means two things that they like the
people they work with and that they feel
that they're doing something that's
truly impactful that might change the
world so how do you design for
meaningfulness and this is where we get
into story what we found in our research
is that individuals and organizations
that are designed for story tend to have
much more meaning and individuals
connected to purpose
and then organizations that don't so
what I'm going to do is talk about why
story shed a little light on the
behavioral science of story illuminate a
couple of misperceptions of story
then I'll go into how to harness it and
then I'll talk about a few ideas of what
I hope you do on Monday so and I should
also give you a little personal insight
well there's three alright first so I'm
an academic I teach these different
classes that are mentioned and I would
always get pretty good ratings but every
time I would teach a class I would want
to revamp it so I would email my
students like from the prior year of the
year before saying what did you remember
from the class I'd love to know because
I'm going to revamp it for this year and
inevitably people would respond saying I
don't remember anything
I remember I really liked your class and
also you have a funny stick where like
if someone has their phone ring you make
them pick it up in the middle of class
and that's hilarious that killed and so
in ten weeks of teaching these like
different marketing classes they only
remembered like a funny joke that I
would do on them because that you know
crushed and so this is demoralizing if
you can't imagine as a teacher because
pretty much your job is to teach and and
if they're not remembering that's that's
problematic and it made sense upon
reflection so I would run all of my
classes because I didn't want people to
think that marketing was a soft subject
so I would run only analytics in my
class and in every class I cold call
them and make sure that they ran
regressions and breakevens and talked
about serial correlation and we'll take
linearity and they were really got very
advanced in their analytics and they
changed their perception of marketing
but we never got to anything else
besides just you better run all of your
analyses and so as I dove into the
science of story I realized that what
happens is when people hear a story
versus just data that there are 22 times
more likely to remember it over a long
haul and so what I was doing in my class
is just running analytics and not ever
having these difference or his stories
punctuated the points is I was making it
so that their experience was pretty
positive but they're not going to
remember anything
the second thing I should notice is
Aaron mentioned is I I went to Berkeley
for two years about six years ago I was
hired there and I usually don't really
like private school and fancy people I
like public school who went to Berkeley
anyway go bears
three of you and and and so I went to
Berkeley I was really excited to be
there and I didn't think I was going to
come back and and so I went off and I
took Ali
from here and I taught this class called
creativity and innovation and and and
one of the basic principles of this
class is that you have to do things we
have to kind of reverse the rules
whatever you've done in the past
consider doing the opposite of it and
then or generating ideas that feel very
opposite and then trying those and
periodically it's going to be a disaster
and but periodically it's going to
actually work out so I tried to do this
on my last lecture my normal last
lecture for these classes is you know I
spend 40 hours and come up with a list
of the top ten things I hope they
remember and then I you know give it to
them this time I didn't do anything I
just asked my students what did you
remember from the class all of my 60
students emailed me back and they gave
me basically bullets of insights one of
my students shared with me a story and
that story about how the class impacted
him had such a dramatic impact on my
life and my husband's life and my
family's life that it completely changed
the way that I parent completely changed
the way I spend my time it completely
changed the research trajectory that I
was on and it completely changed the way
I teach and now I'm much more thoughtful
about story and how it works with data
so even though I'm going to be talking
much more from a strategic level about
the power of story I wanted to share
those two insights because from a very
personal angle these these ideas around
story but have incredible potential to
change not just how you run your
organization but also your life so let
me share a little bit about the
behavioral science of story once upon a
time information is scarce so we made
decisions based on the advice effects
using them as North Stars for instance
now thanks to the internet we can
ourselves try and find our own answers
to questions that plague us and find
information to make informed decisions
but instead of finding clear answers we
often find knows we're living in a world
where we have too much information and
because of that were even more
susceptible to great story it's what
helps us decide what to believe in
stories are important because they're
meaningful and they're meaningful
because they're memorable impactful and
they personally connect first let's talk
about memorability Eugene O'Kelly was a
CEO of a consulting company he started
having headaches he was referred to a
top neurosurgeon in New York where he
was diagnosed a late stage brain cancer
and he was given three months to live he
started talking to his wife how does he
want to spend those hundred days he was
purposeful about who he spent time with
and what stories to share with them he
also thought hard about what would be
remembered in those last 100 days
Tina's wife would live each day with a
focus on finding perfect moments where
time expands and we noise is separated
from signal all that exists is that
single moment and he found in those
perfect moments those were the most
memorable stories that defined his life
in one study researchers asked students
to make a one-minute persuasive pitch to
other members in the class and on
average typical student use 2.5
statistics in their pitch only one in
ten told a story 10 minutes later the
researcher asked everyone to pull out a
sheet of paper and write down every
single idea they remember only 5%
remember any statistic 63% of the
students remember the story stories are
memorable in a way that statistics
aren't now let me talk about impact
research shows that individuals are more
likely to buy from a person or an
organization whose story they believe in
and which resonates with them in one
study Deb small at the University of
Pennsylvania and her colleagues wanted
to determine how to best raise money for
Save the Children a charity focused on
the well-being of children worldwide
they created two versions of a marketing
pamphlet the first version featured
statistics about the magnitude of
problems facing children in Africa the
second version also featured those
statistics but in addition provided
information about Rokia a seven-year-old
girl from Mali who faced the threat of
severe hunger the subjects were given
five dollars as compensation for the
study and before leaving the researchers
asked if they wanted to donate any money
to the cause the individuals in the
story condition gave nearly twice as
much money as those in the statistics
condition
we used to think it was our rational
brain that makes decisions now we know
it's emotion driving decisions and we
rationalized the decision afterwards
finally I want to talk about personal
connection research shows that if we
present statistics to an audience a
certain part of the brain called the
Broca's and Wernicke's area gets
activated so the language processing
part of the brain is activated and we
can understand but not feel when a story
is shared the audience feels the story
our whole brain is activated and meaning
is extracted the meaning of the story
comes from the personal connection the
audience feels when they're listening to
the story and when a story is well told
they're able to feel connected not just
to the story but to the storyteller when
most of us think of advocating for ideas
we go to statistics we go to convincing
arguments facts and figures but studies
show that if we share a story people are
more likely to remember the message be
persuaded by it feel personally
connected to it and when data and
stories are used together audiences are
moved both intellectually and
emotionally for lasting effect you need
to persuade the rational brain but also
resonate with the emotional brain recent
behavioral research has shown why
stories are so powerful it's because
they're meaningful those who tell the
best stories will become the best
leaders if we consider the simple
question what is the story or why am I
doing this we may find we make very
different choices at how we spend our
time
isabel allende once wrote silence before
being born silence after death life is
nothing but noise between those two
unfathomable silences but there is no
and there is noise and how do we reduce
the noise story so good really was very
polite of you
so just to define a story and it's a
narrative at the beginning a middle and
an end
they have arcs they're marked by these
highs and these lows but it's not just
facts features lists to-do lists so
meaning is captured in the story right
because it's longitudinal it's lasting
and how these high as these lows and
involves these characters if you think
about these arcs it's stories when
you're shaping it you're telling people
about something that might feel like a
roller coaster so if you think of you
know movies that we see all the time
James Bond the arc is always you know
what happened I don't know he gets the
girl and every every single James Bond
movie has the exact same and we get
Jurassic Park which was I don't know if
you remember but you know what's going
on t-rex spring on big G rags going on
really really big t-rex so arcs don't
have to be really sophisticated they
just have to like have volatility and or
Casablanca which is known as one of the
best well-crafted arcs in a movie where
these these micro arcs that define the
overall story arc but the funny thing is
most people believe that stories are
really these long epic things and
oftentimes they can be quite cryptic
Ernest Hemingway was once known to have
written one of the first six words
stories he wrote baby shoes for sale
never worn so when I teach the power of
story class I I asked the students
before class to give me a story a story
of you know anything they've written
that they're proud of or a six word
story by the way most all of them just
send me their Stanford essays because
they're so excited to use them again
because they they've worked so hard on
them and
never use them again and they have these
epic stories right because everyone gets
into Stanford not because of their GPA
or the SAT or GMAT it's because of these
stories their essays and their
recommendation right the stories of the
differentiator you're banking on people
joining their team wanting them to come
to places because of the stories that
they tell and others tell about them so
but I do make my students tell these
six-word stories and write them and
introduce each other to them here's a
few not quite aspiring to be to be quite
tonight he packs tomorrow i prime
married the wrong girl fixed it getting
old ringtones pissing me off
so they don't like to view these big
epic stories they could be sort of a
moment in time or something kind of
innocuous but it defines you so I'm
gonna give you 30 seconds to write a six
word story about yourself so take out a
piece of paper um and just six word
story thirty seconds it could be funny
or epic or meaningful one tip is that it
ideally you've changed so you used to be
this and now you're that because that
kind of forces you to think in terms of
an arc or some sort of transformation so
30 seconds six word story
you
all right now grab the person next to
you or a couple of people like get in
groups of two three or four and just
share the six words store you guys have
30 seconds to share your six word story
all right quickly
all right finishing up all right
I'm just it does anyone did anyone here
like an epic six word story will you
just point to the person who like said a
six word story can you stand up in the
white or right around there yeah someone
else nominate there something you heard
come on
all right in the red your Willie I'm
well-liked five let's see
Oh back there please please stand up
you've been nominated congratulations
there's big awards oh right there right
there yes in the blue come on one more
let's get a female let's go crazy
all right well oh you know can you stand
up thank you all right so we got five
people I think right one two three four
five awesome okay so all you're gonna do
is someone in red is gonna come over and
grab and give you a mic I think are you
not nominated thank you very much
okay so you're just gonna say your name
to everyone and then your six words
store I will clap and you can sit down
all right Michael mazia I left New York
City cxp boom done bye that might be
more than six words right
sevenish okay great let's in the back
happy old and stressed younger now I
know everyone knows you about like yeah
just like I know everyone knows you
Peter Kelly it's just like yeah just cuz
you know it's polite
alright so Gerald risk was wound up then
let go I'm Alessandra Alvis from Brazil
built it sewed it now what right over
here okay you got Brett Forrester
Everland found Neverland Never Say Never
[Applause]
okay any observations like shout out any
observations from those six-word stories
just like anything that surprised you
it's all about business yeah they're
pretty clear so they could contain a lot
of meaning they might be about business
or career transition or whatever but
they also often feel quite personal and
four six words actually communicate a
lot of meaning any other observations
yeah in America we like those yeah if I
had more international people I don't
know I think yours was a little bit less
like who knows what now what might be
happy might be sad but you're right
there's cultural definitions of Arc's
Russians for example aren't quite as
happy focused as we are
North Korea don't know except anyway I'm
getting derailed um yeah observation
yeah like so half of them you're like I
get it I understand you say no more and
others are almost invitations to have
more conversations what we find there's
one study I never published but we asked
half of our executives at the beginning
of a session to do the six word story
and then the other half I asked them at
the end of this session and we took the
metrics on how much they wanted to spend
time together whether they wanted to get
a beer together whether they wanted to
work on a group project together
and the group that was exposed to this
little short exercise at the very
beginning or substantially closer and
more intrigued to get to know each other
than the people that didn't do that
exercise there's something that story
that makes you feel more connected to
others and we can go on and on for all
of the behavioral scientific reasons for
that and the neuroscience behind that
but it's true people feel closer but
it's also strategic I recently did a
session for Adam silver the NBA
commissioner and what we do is you got
all 32 basketball teams in a room very
similar to this and all 32 teams were in
different rooms and so you have your own
ORS there and you have all the top
management so about like let's say 10 or
12 people at each table and we ran three
different exercises and I'll take you
through them really quickly but they're
all six words stories and six words
stories about purpose what's the team's
purpose what's its mission what does it
stand for the second one was these user
stories how are you gonna make your
season ticket-holder the hero of their
own story so it's not about you or the
team or the NBA it's about the the
customer and then the third is the
growth story which was where's this team
going and and so we did the same
exercise 30 seconds write down these six
words stories and then they all shared
those stories in their little tables and
what at least Adam said and I totally
was that the highest performing teams
not just the teams that were making the
most in terms of global sales and being
the most innovative but also the teams
that were the most coherent were those
that actually when they share their
six-word stories they were strikingly
similar but the teams that were
underperforming and really struggling
and they
worried about it with an NBA link were
those within 30 seconds you could tell
the team did not have any consensus
around what is our story what do we
stand for what value are we creating for
the customer and where are we going
and and so something as powerful as a
six word story which was really succinct
is best able oftentimes to capture what
really is the meaning of an entity a
family and organization so I wanted to
just my goal is for you in a year's time
if I ever see you walking down the
street and I say what did you remember
in this session it would be more than
like these five six word stories you
know it would be a couple other things
so I created this talk with a hope that
you could go back to your organization
or even your family and hopefully be
able to start using story much more
effectively than perhaps you have but to
do that you have to identify these
misperceptions of story
now the first one I find the most
frequent is that a lot of people feel
like stories are communication or
branding or marketing but they're not
one of my favorite quotes is by Ben
Horowitz
I've andreessen horowitz and he writes
the company story is the company's
strategy the story must explain why you
exist why are we doing this why does the
problem need to be solved why should you
join the company why should you invest
in us why should you buy a product from
us and the story that you create when
it's when it's concise when it's clear
it addresses pretty much all of these
questions and they're found everywhere
it's not just communication but there's
stories on websites in these blog posts
and videos that we create in the happy
hours the conversations we informally
have through obviously social media and
even something as small as a six word
story exercise so it's not just
communication the second misperception I
often find especially with engineers
although the engineers are the ones that
tend to like this content the most
because they see the the science in it
is that they believe stories are kind of
the opposite of days
yeah but when you're leading and you
have a point of view and you're trying
to persuade you have two tools right you
have this data here and you have these
stories user stories your own stories
your employees stories and when you're
in some contexts like a board meeting
versus a one-on-one versus a company
treat sometimes you're gonna have one
minute in front of someone and you'll go
80% into data and 20% on story and
another context you're gonna go 20% on
data and 80% on story so it really these
are two tools so even though I showed
you that initial slide to debunk the
myth that data isn't story because also
large data sets create stories the other
way to think about it is you've got
these two tools and you want both of
them in your portfolio another way that
a lot of times people will remember this
is and I'd like you to do this to think
about when you make a one-minute
persuasive pitch to a board member an
employee anyone are you the type of
person who usually leads with your point
of view and then backs it up with data
and then ends with a story or are you
the kind of person that starts at the
point of view contextualizes it with a
story and then back set up with data or
do you hook people a story back it up
with data and and let them infer the
point of view or are you a data oriented
person and then mainly come with story
and then follow it up and by the way as
you think about this you might have
changed I have a friend shell Sandberg
at Facebook who used to always be point
of view data no story and over time
she's really changed and she really has
story and then it's backed up with data
and that it ends with a point of view I
recently gave it talk at Genentech and
they said that their formula isn't up
here and they said we're just data data
data we have no point of view nor any
stories so it might be different for you
but just quick raise of a hands and I
know there's different contortions these
are just for the more common ones raise
your hand if you're more point of view
data story raise your hand if you're
more point of view story data story data
point of view data story point of view
okay so you're pretty well represented
although the
or left quadrant is is by far the
predominant and so the the way that to
think about this is that even if you are
story data point of view and that's why
it's natural for you or that's what your
culture your organization values think
about different ways of using these
components because different audiences
are persuaded for different reasons and
the last is that many people don't feel
that there's an ROI to story just a
quick anecdote bonobos which was
launched here as an online apparel
company Stanford many years ago they
were a data oriented company where they
could find out where there's pockets
product opportunities and then when they
would launch them based on this data
insight one time they launched a gene
called bold denim and it was a great
product their data said that there was
no current product in that space of like
good fitting clothes for guys but sales
were underperforming they asked
customers what they loved about the
jeans and learned that the men really
love to travel on them so they kept
hearing these epic stories of traveling
with the like three people who bought
the jeans and so they renamed the travel
jeans at each style for a different
destination and all they did was change
and add about six or seven words to
their exact same frame before they added
mid weight travel jeans and then they
said ideal for excursions to temperate
zones near and far within one month the
entire category the Jean category not
just bold on that dumb increase in
category sells from 7 to 15% that was
the only change and the other categories
didn't show a similar change so there's
ways to think about stories as providing
context and you can do a/b testing to
understand what actually drives behavior
so I wanted to talk briefly about how to
harness story before I kind of leave you
with a few tips and maybe take a couple
questions so there's three really
important ways to think about story one
is how do you use stories to lead and
that stories with data are tools of
power and we have this class called
humor serious business and different
types of stories we find a lot of our
CEOs really leverage humor and really
effective ways and so the
these stories don't have to be these
meaningful impactful stories they can
also be humorous or defuse tension and
creep ons but they can be very powerful
the second is stories as actually
strategic assets and the third is
stories as a way of living a way of just
making decisions for your family for
yourself to create a more meaningful
life and using time with intent I joked
with Peter that I actually I forgot that
this is about power story so yesterday I
was working on the talk and I created a
big talk actually around how do you use
time in strategic ways and there's so
much work done on meaning and and and
money like how to use money in
meaningful ways but there's not as much
work on time and and so if anyone's
interested in that I'm happy to share it
with you that Dec but I'm not going to
talk about the those two I'll talk in
the remainder this time much more on how
you can think of stories as strategic
assets so what is a strategic asset is a
story in the many stories we find in
organizations is that stories are very
tactical but signature stories are
strategic and they're an asset that
really managed men as merits investment
and management so my dad and I actually
wrote an article together recently it's
called what is your signature story and
we define signature stories as
intriguing authentic involving stories
with a strategic message that drives
growth by enhancing the organization the
brand and/or the business strategy so it
often really three key ones that I talk
a lot about our the purpose story it
illuminates what you stand for the user
is hero story which is the value you
create and the growth story where you're
going now when you ask people what are
your strategic stories that are defining
or signature you often get at least
leaders being able to rapidly easily
give you what are their signature
stories are and if they don't then
they're the people around them do so a
couple of examples
CEO named Rob
whole one of his strategic stories or
signature stories that he says all the
time as he was rejected 70 times by
venture capitalists and weathered the
2008 financial crisis on his way to
building a software company and at one
point he actually had to suspend his
salary and consider selling the company
as it couldn't find a Series B investor
and this is ripe like the moment before
you know he actually got Goldman to do a
significant asset but he's he tells that
story again and again about like the
highs and the lows of his career another
example is ChiHong who's at boxed and he
came out as a CEO with this idea of
helping to pay for kids colleges he
realized that basically what was so
important to him was education and then
he found out that many of his employees
couldn't even afford to hold after work
events because they needed to take care
of their kids and they couldn't even
send their kids to school so he created
an initiative and he said if you're a
child if someone who works at boxed it's
not because of the lack of money it's
gonna prevent your kid from going to
college or you we're gonna build a
long-term business and if you're along
on the ride we're going to basically pay
for college for every single one of your
kids and that story gets told and retold
within the company and it's a real
reason to not just go but to stay the
harder thing to do is these signature
stories about your company so I wanted
to breeze through three of them and I'm
gonna have you write down six-word
stories to capture your own work as well
just like with the MBA so there's these
purpose stories that clarify value and
create differentiation these users hero
stories that show how much empathy you
have for your customer and how much
value you really create and these growth
stories that elevate value and also
increase pipeline my favorite purpose
story is Tom's where the CEO often says
having a story is what separates us
people don't just wear our shoes they
tell our story so I think we can all
agree that TOMS shoes are really ugly
shoes can we all agree all right most of
you can agree that TOMS shoes are ugly
shoes yet my daughter who's 11
predominantly wears TOMS shoes and she
thinks they're actually good-looking
shoes and the reason she thinks they're
good-looking shoes is because they have
the story like she knows that these very
expensive shoes they'll have you know
another shoe donated to a child in a
developing country and that at some
level makes her feel connected and Tom's
has done a tremendous job of actually
executing on that promise people want to
be valued members of a winning team on
an inspired mission and you you have to
have every single one of those words
working for you and what I find it most
companies is that that inspired mission
is not clear there's no consensus and
it's not well understood not just among
the employees but also the customer I
mean the CEO and the leadership gallop
ran a poll with over a million people
last year and asked individuals do you
feel like you understand the mission of
your company or the purpose of the
company 80% said no other 20% who said
yes seventy-five percent said that they
didn't care and we have a lot of health
data a lot of productivity data to show
that people work much harder they get
sick far less frequently when they feel
connected to something that's meaningful
or purposeful it's just a tremendous
waste stefanos has worked with Jeff
Pfeffer that shows that literally
workplace environments are killing us
and I think the correlation between
increased work and the health detriments
that are happening is not completely
independent from the fact that the work
environments that we've set up for the
people that work for us and with us are
not healthy and one of the problems is
80 percent don't know what the mission
or the larger purpose of their company
is and of those who do they don't
personally feel themselves connected to
it so if you can't get to a place of
feeling valued feeling like you're on a
team you don't want to be winning all
the time but you have to have a path
toward winning and then feel like you
all know your role on the in the purpose
and the mission
then you get these dramatic reduced hits
to productivity and health Steph says
often times and you win when everyone
touches the ball for those of you don't
follow basketball he's a very important
basketball player and and and and he
talks a lot about this notion of what is
the winning team where everyone feels
valued everyone touches the ball and we
all feel like we're on the same team you
have to feel authentic when you share
this story or that mission people can
tell when you aren't and the problem
right now is that brands often feel Mac
manufactured companies often feel
manufactured certainly our politicians
feel often quite manufactured but people
people who we know people whose story we
understand and believe in they don't and
they cut through and we trust those
people and even those five signature
stories told in six words makes you feel
like you kind of know each of these five
individuals so the leaders that do this
well often do not just articulate a
purpose but they do so in very authentic
ways so one of you know a very I don't
know sort of favorable easy anecdote to
point to is Dollar Shave Club which is
you know sold for 1 billion to Unilever
with no marketing budget basically a
very little money for PR the the CEO
launched a video that explained their
purpose and did it with a very clear
brand personality very clear brand
personality and that had all the made
all the difference
dollarshaveclub.com what is
dollarshaveclub.com well for $1 a month
we sent high-quality razors right to
your door yeah a dollar are the blades
any good no our blades are great each
razor has stainless steel blades in a
levira lubricating strip and a pivot
head it's so gentle a toddler could use
it and do you like spending $20.00 a
month on brand-name razors 19 go to
Roger Federer
I'm good at tennis do you think your
razor needs a vibrating handle a
flashlight a backscratcher in ten blades
your nets amass grandfather had one
blade and polio
looking good pop up stop hand for shave
tech you don't need and stop forgetting
to buy your blades every month 100 I are
gonna ship them right to you we're not
just selling razors we're also making
new jobs Alejandra what were you doing
last month not working what are you
doing now waking I'm no Vanderbilt but
this train makes hay
so stop forgetting about your blades
every month and start deciding where
you're gonna stack all those dollar
bills I'm saving you
we are dollarshaveclub.com and the party
is on always love all Hondros film Paris
yeah anyway I'm from a financial from a
financial perspective they grew and in
large part it was due to this authentic
charismatic story filled leader who had
a clear purpose um so I'm just 30
seconds really quickly write down six
words or less your companies and if
you're changing companies right now you
can think about your last company or
your hopeful future a company six word
story about the company really anchor on
what you think is the mission so if you
were here with your senior team
hopefully they're all gonna write down
the same type of six words
go ahead 30 seconds I think it could be
like do no evil or whatever if you're
Google or you know it doesn't have to be
six words
all right and by the way you can do this
with your team like this takes all of
minute and a half and the type of
insights is just remarkable
the second signature story that's really
important to nail down is this user as
here as story and all of the individuals
that are trained in design thinking here
at Stanford know this you know how to do
this really well a lot of technology
companies do too but brands too often
make the mistake of trying to be the
hero your customers or users are the
hero but now LinkedIn and Facebook and
YouTube all of these companies have done
a really good job not of marketing but
of collecting these user stories and
then banking them on these websites all
of these websites I'm showing you have
thousands of hundreds of thousands of
user stories with all have the exact
same arc which is ordinary person faces
extraordinary odds to achieve something
quite remarkable by means of Google or
YouTube or Facebook or LinkedIn exact
same exact same arc a good example of
this was Google who does not believe in
marketing they don't hire anyone with
marketing in the title maybe now but
barely and and they don't think they're
good communicators or they don't believe
in brand so it's really frustrating for
them when they come up with a really
strong product made by engineers and it
doesn't take off because they don't
believe in marketing so they can't yell
louder and when they do they yell about
features and that doesn't change
people's behavior one day the creative
head Robert Wong went to his team and
said we've got to make Google Chrome
take off it's a better product than
other search engines no one's adopting
it why not and one of the people in the
room basically storyboarded out his
story and this is what it looks like
[Music]
today
[Applause]
[Music]
you
so that ad then became their Superbowl
ad and now they're basically the best
marketers I know it also increased it's
like so their fault and they have this
incredible campaign around it it's all
users heroes stories Daniel II who what
did work at Google you know you saw that
story wasn't about Google Chrome it was
about you know Picasa and YouTube and
Gmail and all of these different things
so the hero was Daniel Lee and the
Google Chrome was just kind of
background player and the thing that's
interesting is that it led to a 6%
uptick in Google Chrome downloads in the
one week after the the launch of this so
it had a dramatic impact
so again 30 seconds of what is who's
your customer you could just think of
one person if you want and how do you
help make them the hero of their story
in this case Daniel Lee was a better dad
because of Google products and that
really made him a hero I have a
girlfriend in the back who's an
entrepreneur Wendy Riker who does these
really remarkable things with all of her
kids making her kids feel like they are
heroes of their own story so oops
sorry about that all right 30 seconds
write down the name of your user or your
customer or or whatever and just write
down a single six word story where you
think you could help make them the hero
of their story in some way
last grouse story knowing where you're
going my favourite anecdote here is is
coca-cola who where three or four years
ago they had no idea how to leverage
social and digital media and their their
all their communication wasn't working
and so they they got this book that we
wrote called the Dragonfly effect my
husband and I wrote this book together
mostly to inspire our kids to do good
things in the world we wanted them to be
like Kennedy kids but without the
drinking issues and and so we wrote a
book you know and also like if anything
happened to us you know they would see a
dragonfly and knew like we were
connected to them so it was a very
meaningful endeavor but weirdly it got
picked up by all these for-profit
companies that wanted to make change in
the world and this is like the least
inspirational anecdote but it's a super
funny anecdote because you know coke is
sugar water but it was still a really
interesting case they did not know how
to connect two teens globally harnessing
social and digital media so they used
this design thinking approach saying our
single focus goal which is the key part
you know what is your purpose in this
campaign was very clear connect to keep
teens globally harnessing social and
digital media and then instead of taking
$350,000 in giving it to their marketing
team they created seven groups of 50
grand and gave it to seven different
teams of marketing and on marketing
people and said go get this goal and six
of the teams bomb they created apps and
screen savers but one of the team's
approached their goal
[Music]
[Applause]
so that was an organic treat they didn't
SEO this but that hit 20 million views
in two weeks mmm the blog comments were
95% positive 50% English and 50% not
English and but what was interesting
about this is that like all these people
started writing in saying I want a coke
ah penis machine on my campus and my
company and they originally started like
kind of throwing away these these notes
and emails but they realized that this
actually fundamentally changed how they
thought of themselves as a growth
company they all anchored on this six
word story of creating surprising
moments of authentic happiness and that
completely chant transformed how they
spent their budget and the other reason
this is an interesting story is that if
you look at their budget what they do is
they spend seventy percent on what
actually works you know which drives
revenue but 20 percent of what they're
doing all of their content and most
interesting companies are are basically
now editors of magazines they're not
really like you know CPG companies but
20% of their marketing budget goes to
very new stories and 10% go to customer
generated co-created stories and then
they test each of these stories and some
of the 20% go into the subsequent year
70% some of the 10% customer generated
stories going to the 20% new initiatives
so 30 seconds just write your six word
story where you're going down six words
or less
okay so I wanted to end with a couple of
things that I hope you do one I am next
week I hope you think more about the
stories you're using to lead the stories
that your company may be banking as
assets and even thinking about what
stories you're sharing at the dinner
table instead of what you do today
instead could you say you know share a
story of what happened and we started
doing that with our three young kids and
they started taking much bigger risk
because they're really excited to come
home and share a story of what they did
that sidestepped a bully or wouldn't
make us would make us like sort of take
our breath away and it it fundamentally
changed the way our family lives like
now every year we move away for four
months to do a family sabbatical in New
York or Sweden or Stockholm by the way
we want to go to South America next so
if anyone has any connections let us
know but the reason is because you don't
remember the day to day you only
remember when you move physical
dislocation you only remember those
moments you're uncomfortable also it was
really fun because they don't have any
friends in other places so they're
forced to be with us so there's a lot of
reasons to think about how do you like
think of creative life design anchored
on the stories that you could bring
about this year or what stories of
define your last year when we ask this
to our students and our subjects they
don't remember anything about last year
it's not just my class but they don't
remember it's everything but they
remember stories so I hope you audit
your current stories both internally for
your employees as well as externally
it's really easy to do just taking
inventory of how consistent and coherent
they are I hope you get clear on three
your purpose story your userís hero and
empathy story and your growth story I
hope you start banking your stories and
maybe it's on a website or maybe it's
just through Google slides their assets
and if you anchor on those two stories
the bold stories those stories that are
distinct relevant to different audiences
memorable so they stick over time
evergreen so they grow in value over
time and they depict something bigger
some inspired mission that connotes and
convey
meaning and then you do that every five
or ten years as the story of our lives
changes I I think your life will be much
more meaningful so I'll end with my
favorite quote which is tell me the
facts and I'll learn tell me the truth
and I'll believe but tell me a story and
it will live in my heart forever thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]